you
you
you
welcome everybody good a good afternoon
good evening good morning depending on
where you are I just ate a banana if you
can believe it and I am ready to go
peeled it the right way by the way not
the wrong way good good luck figuring
out what the right way in the wrong way
is we are standing by for a Donald Trump
cabinet meeting we are of course
expecting questions about Donald Trump's
claim yesterday that he is taking
hydroxy chloroquine as he says it and I
question whether he is we'll talk about
that in a little bit I have filmed but
not uploaded a full urban garden tour I
show people my cucumbers I expose my
tomatoes the full thing I filmed it it's
fantastic but I have not yet uploaded it
and I probably will upload it to my
Instagram a little bit later today or
maybe tomorrow you would be impressed
with the size of some of my tomatoes
that I've got already
and the cukes are moving a little slowly
but we will certainly get to those let's
go through some of the latest numbers oh
I do have one super chat before I jump
in and feel free to get your super chats
in zesty African our good friend zesty
says David Pakman more like David the
dude man your favorite three presidents
hope all is well thank you you know I
don't do lists or superlatives I really
couldn't tell you my favorite three
presidents eras are so different it's
hard to compare how do you compare
Washington to Obama you know you really
can't other than skin color Corey Keene
says which president lied the least in
the last 30 years which president lied
the least and the less so that would get
us back to 1990 Bush won Clinton Bush to
Obama and Trump I mean listen I think
Trump lied the most I don't know I mean
here's the thing bush and Clinton were
in an era where the lies Presidents Bush
one in Clinton were in an era where the
lies presidents were willing to tell our
were not as egregious as what is now
seen it's very hard that's a really
tough question I don't know the answer
Walker Anderson says check yourself
Cuomo said yesterday there they are only
using 1/3 of their testing capacity per
day who cares about global pet capita
this Walker Anderson person spends a lot
of money just trying to like antagonize
me and catch me and it's so boring
ken Clive says this is for your
watermelon fund also things are starting
to look better in LA what social
distancing is proving itself here
infection rate is steadily decreasing
take care David Jamaal Swift is back at
Jamal says hey homey hey great to see
you Jamal haven't seen you around for a
bit
Matt Chavez says he's fed Hydroxycut but
doesn't know the difference right yeah I
actually have a let me see if I can find
it I put a poll on my Twitter page which
you can participate in which asks is
Trump taking hydroxy chloroquine yes he
thinks so meaning he's taking something
but somebody gave him a placebo or no
and he knows he isn't so you can
actually vote and that is one of the
options that Trump is taking something
else and doesn't know it only roughly
one out of what one out of ten of my
Twitter uh Twitter followers thinks
Trump is actually taking
hydroxychloroquine and we will we'll get
to more about that momentarily okay let
me I guess I got through the early Super
chats so let me step away from those and
then I'll get right back to them latest
coronavirus numbers officially we are
potentially just hours from our five
millionth official case globally and we
are well past three hundred and twenty
thousand deaths at this point in time
looking at yesterday's numbers for the
most new cases of course USA number one
but Brazil increasingly a hot spot
Russia increasingly a hot spot and India
increasingly a hot spot those are three
places that are increasingly having a
tough go of it and we are going to be
following them very closely here in the
United States
we are approaching 1.6 million official
cases and before we know it we will be
at a hundred thousand deaths maybe in
about a week or so maybe a little less
maybe a little more yesterday in terms
of new cases Illinois now dramatically
out in front in terms of new cases you
see New Jersey California continues to
get worse New York and Massachusetts
have had problems for a while Texas now
regularly at the top of the list Florida
and Virginia are regularly making
appearances near the top and in terms of
testing per capita Rhode Island
continues to be the tops followed by
North Dakota New York Massachusetts New
Mexico now regularly testing a lot a lot
of people and so on down in terms of
total tests on Sunday we did for the
first time hit 400,000 tests here in the
United States fell almost a hundred
thousand short of that yesterday and of
course as you know we probably need to
be testing between 1 and 5 million
people a day the new talking point from
the trumpet right and trumpets
themselves are there's more capacity
than people to test the answer is only
if you are restricting tests to people
with symptoms or people exposed to
people with symptoms we need to be doing
widespread surveillance testing if we
have all of this excess capacity start a
surveillance program tell people if
you're 65 or older you can now get a
test regardless of symptoms regardless
of whether you've been exposed to
someone with symptoms start a program
where you say next week everybody with
last names A through e go in and get a
test expand expand who should be going
and getting tests it's very easy to say
as you expand capacity to some degree we
have too many tests if you say you can
only get a test if you have symptoms or
know you've been around someone who has
the virus let's start getting more
people testing surveillance testing
that's what South Korea did
that's what Taiwan did etc etc etc
yesterday a Donald Trump did claim to be
taking hydroxychloroquine take a listen
to this me whistleblower and this other
guy with the hydroxychloroquine
okay well he he went out and he's the
one that approved the hydroxychloroquine
he's the one that signed the application
he also happens to be if you look see
whether or not I won't put it on me I'll
put it in you see whether or not he was
a big contributor to the Democrats right
see whether or not he wanted the
Democrats to win know there's a lot of
bad things coming out about him but you
people don't want to write the the news
you know but if you look but he's the
one that signed the application at the
very important form he signed it now if
he doesn't believe in it why would he
sign it and a lot of good things have
come out about the hydroxi a lot of good
things of young man and you'd be
surprised at how many people are taken
and especially the frontline workers
before you catch it the frontline
workers many many are taking it I happen
to be taking it I happen to be taken
couple of weeks he's high right now on
it yeah started taking it so he says he
took it started a couple of weeks ago
the proper dosage of hydroxychloroquine
is one dose per week you normally would
started a week before you go to a
country where you risk getting a malaria
catching malaria it's one dose per week
so when Trump says I've been taking it
for a couple of weeks does he mean he
got two doses is he doing the Sean
Hannity method where you take it daily
which is of course very very dangerous
we don't know but check out this letter
that was put out the letter put out by
his doctor doesn't actually say that
Trump is taking it it says as has been
previously reported two weeks ago one of
the president's support staff tested
positive for kovat 19 the president is
in very good health and has remained
symptom free he receives regular kovat
19:00 testing all negative to date and
then it says after numerous discussions
he and I had regarding the evidence for
and against the use of hydroxy
chloroquine we concluded the potential
benefit from treatment I'll wait out
weighed the relative risks that's a
theoretical conversation this doesn't
actually say and so we put trump on it
and then it says you know in
consultation we will continue to follow
the literature on hydroxychloroquine the
better that they put out supposedly to
defend that Trump is on it doesn't
actually say Trump is on it so take that
you know take that for what it's worth I
don't know that Donald Trump is actually
taking hydroxychloroquine we are in the
room here and we are standing by for a
Donald Trump cabinet meeting I do want
to make sure that you consider yourself
invited to grab a membership on my
website at join pakman.com i it's it's
in vogue and vogue in vogue to always
pretend like everything is going
fantastic but I've been up front
we lost 722 members in March and April
because of the virus we've already lost
about another 175 in May if you can
afford to support the work we do I'm
talking about two bucks a month that's
the ask it's not anything big
grab a membership at join pakman.com
that coupon code right there 2020 now
saves you 66% that makes it 2 bucks a
month or 20 for the year that's like a
dollar 80 a month ok I don't want
anybody's last dollar we're all in this
together we're upping our weekly
production nobody has been laid off no
reductions in ours and it is primarily
funded by those memberships and I will
thank everybody every single one of you
who grabs a membership today I will
thank you more than profusely on stream
just you wait just you wait
ok a couple of other super chats coming
in Walker Anderson says I am not
antagonizing I am correcting you that
the United States has surpassed demand
with testing capacity Cuomo confirmed
this yesterday that's if you do no
surveillance testing and we should be
doing surveillance testing that's you
don't fight this by only testing
symptomatic people you fight this with
surveillance testing it could be up to
half of people are asymptomatic so we we
still do not have that level of capacity
Joe Rader says David is a prepper have
you considered putting in a solar system
with battery backup Tesla and others
have made it feasible technologically
and financially I have thought about it
I'm not really a prepper I'm a casual
left-wing prepper
thanks to coronavirus I have thought
about solar I have thought about solar
Rp
clapping because Trump is coming in
let's see oh he is here so welcome to
our cabinet meeting and every member of
my cabinet is working let's actually
switch over to the White House feed I
think it's a better feeds in the fox
news feed slightly delayed thanks by the
way for the membership thanks Ann you
are number one number one in my book
number one for life thanks Sam so
welcome to our cabinet meeting and every
member of my cabinet is working
tirelessly to defeat the invisible enemy
that should have never happened to our
country should have never happened to
the world it came from China it's a
disgrace could have been stopped at the
source but they decided not to do that
but we're going to safely we open our
country and our economy and it's
happening very rapidly and it's
happening interestingly when numbers are
actually going down you look at Florida
the state of Florida and a great job you
look at Georgia you look at others
they're open and some are doing
extremely well far beyond accused of
just lying about the numbers and the
numbers are going down the numbers that
we have been talking about for the last
two months they're actually going down
so it's really terrific in our drive to
crush the virus the US has completed
nearly 12 million tests and that tests
that number today is almost 14 million
nobodies close Germany would be second
with approximately 10 million less than
us Anatolia the best tests were at 11
South Korea's doing very well but we're
14 million of their numbers that are
very small by comparison what has been
done with testing what's been done with
ventilators what's been done with the
distribution of product has been
incredible we've made a lot of Governors
look very good yeah we've actually made
all of the governors look very good some
have done a good job but we've made them
all look very good
we got them equipment and they got the
door in rustle by the way for signing up
on my website thank you like nobody
would have thought possible
vaccines are moving quickly into phase
one and phase two trials and trials of
dozens of therapies and cures are
underway and we're making tremendous
strides with therapies cures and
vaccines I think we're way ahead of
schedule and you probably heard
logistically we have our military
engaged and as soon as we have whatever
it is that we're going to have whether
it's therapeutic or vaccine that's at or
and Russell not Thor in the Terry is
ready to go they can deploy hundreds of
thousands of men and women a day and now
what they're going to be doing is
they're going to be doing the vaccine
which we are geared up for even before
we have it but the chances of us having
it are extraordinary thanks to Michael
to secretary a czar will update us on
all that we're doing to safeguard
Americans be talking in a second Elvia
to protect our people and defeat the
virus we must also defend the health of
our nation's economy these cigars to
Trump's left is he gonna pass out
stogies and everybody's gonna cheer
celebrate the victory and of schedule
secretary Carson will update us on the
White House opportunity and
revitalization Council I'll be excited
and you've done a fantastic job we
appreciate it
he's looking at HUD much differently
than people that would have been in the
pure real estate business and he has a
way of seeing things that's different
and really good for our country right
and Ben's working on very hard different
plans to restore health and prosperity
to disadvantaged and minority
communities and that's really working
out well one of the things we're very
proud of his opportunities owns Tim
Scott of South Carolina came to me with
a proposal and few people understand how
success proper tunity zones have been
it's a great tribute to Tim and to
others in the Senate that helped us with
that the pandemic has shown once again
the vital importance of economic
independence and bringing supply chains
back
from China and other countries I
probably got elected one of the primary
reasons was that make America great
again America first caller whatever you
mostly got elected because he tricked 63
million people thanks to Kim and Holger
as well
go to 12 countries to build a car I want
to build a car from one country we make
the parts to achieve this goal we've
slashed red tape and bureaucracy and
unleashed the largest industrial
mobilization since World War two
especially when it comes to big things
like a ventilator it's a very big clumsy
highly sophisticated it's not that big
and it's relatively simple ley lines
where the talk of the world we're
supplying them to other countries
we're helping other countries that are
going through this plague and they're
never going to be able to do ventilators
so we are it's really been an incredible
thing what's happened it's the biggest
mobilization since World War two thanks
Terry and we're fighting for the
livelihoods of American workers and we
must continue to cut through every piece
of red tape that stands in our way and
that's why this is such an exciting
meeting beyond being a cabinet meeting
which is always good right because with
millions of Americans forced out of work
by the virus it's more important than
ever to remove burdens that destroy
American jobs in a few minutes I will
sign an executive order instructing
federal agencies to use any and all
authority to waive suspend and eliminate
unnecessary regulations that impede
economic recovery meaningless executive
order bit that way we want to leave it
that way in some cases we won't be able
to but in other cases we will and you've
heard me say many times I've said and
I've said it very strongly that
regulations we've done more regulation
cutting than any president in history
whether they're there for that's a lie
four years eight years or in one case
what's an outright lie and it's nothing
to brag but more regulation cutting I
don't mean just in a year or two years I
mean in the three-and-a-half years that
we've been here we've cut far more
regulations by a factor of a lot than
any
their administration total presidency so
that's really something it's just not
true I'm directing agencies to review
the hundreds of regulations we've
already suspended in response to the
virus and make these suspensions
permanent where possible
I'm also instructing agencies to use
this is where no one applies critical
thinking like give us a specific
regulation that is right now causing a
problem in terms of coronavirus if I
mean if we identifies things that need
to be suspended let's do it and some
have been identified by big programs
just getting around normal operating
procedure but this vague thing of we're
struggling because of regulations give
us a specific regulation that is causing
a problem right now here's an years to
build a simple roadway or a simple
building and it would end up costing an
absolute fortune many many times what it
should cost and it would take years
before you could even seek final
approval five years seven years 20 years
21 years a certain highway built
recently a small Iowa I would call it a
road 21 years to get it approved and
then by the time they get it approved it
costs so it actually looks like a lot of
the regulations he wants to reduce have
nothing to do with the virus and they're
going to be handouts to his construction
industry friends not surprising with
Elaine and Department of Transportation
we're down to a two year period we want
to see if we can do better we have roads
in there for 18 17 20 21 years over the
years I'm not blaming Elaine for that
I'm just saying over the years there
have been roads that have gone through a
process that the lanes how many years
roadside highways so we're gonna be
getting it down to a year and maybe it's
not going to get passed for
environmental reasons or safety reasons
yeah but we're gonna you know what we
want to do just to help my construction
buddies it's not environmentally sound
and it's not sound in terms of safety so
it may go nowhere but I am gonna sign
this executive order today did you hear
what I said soon to be permanent
director okay that's a big statement
some people would say that's big news
he's done a fantastic job
so congratulations yeah well we have to
get him to approve
we'll give you a congratulations just
prior to approval right so you're doing
great thank you very much
so acting OMB director reservoir will
present details on this effort and we'll
go into that so Russ has done a great
job on exactly what where he used to
come into my office and it's a I think
we can cut a lot of different things in
terms of regulation Trump's gonna chug
some hydroxy soon the better product
it's actually going to give us a better
result and we're adhering to
environmental the environmental impact
studies and all of the other things we
have to do to get these permits but so
Russ vote thank you very much I want to
once again thank every member the calf
and for your commitment to helping our
nation your guess is reopened to recover
and rebuild I'd like to now ask a man
who's done a fantastic job is the head
of the task force he's worked literally
I mean I think literally 24 hours a day
sometimes to make sure everything's gone
well today we had a really great article
by rich Lowry who talked about the
tremendous job that we've done rich
Lowry is supposedly a smart conservative
watch a recent interview he did I forget
where where he tries to explain Obama
gait it might have been an article now
if he's the smartest they've got were
they're in trouble we're all in trouble
so very much because there's been a very
false narrative people have no idea what
an incredible job the people in federal
government have done and that includes
generals and admirals and lots of others
sergeant's not so I want to thank Mike
Pence for the great job you've done Mike
and please say a few words Thank You mr.
president
for your great leadership as president
and
I think everyone around this cabinet
knows that from the first day of this
administration you've made it clear that
you have no higher priority than the
safety and security of the American
people in January when you took the
unprecedented action of suspending all
travel from China before there was oh
yes because what he says doesn't matter
I'm gonna take this opportunity just to
thank a few of the people who just
signed up on my website I think you're
all much more important than Mike Pence
Danielle Jones karidian as well as Terry
Bradbury Kim dye comb Holger Montez Daka
as well as Rosalyn woody
Michael golden Thor so Lee Russell
Berkeley and Ann Cottone thank you guys
I really do appreciate your support and
I like you all so much better than I
like Mike Pence and you can join them
with a membership at Joint Backman
dot-com a mr. president that you asked
me to lead the White House coronavirus
task force we have we have focused on
the health of the American people it
would be on March 15 that your direction
right that we released the the White
House coronavirus guidelines for America
we asked a lot of the American people
here and the American people responded
15 days would become 45 days and in that
time it was our objective mr. president
as you made clear to save lives
right to slow the spread to flatten the
curve and because of what the American
people did because of the direction that
you gave and all the dedicated members
at HHS and FEMA and all of those around
this table who served on the task force
because of the partnership that you
forge with every governor of both
political parties across the country
we've made great progress
that being said mr. president I know
that you believe as we all do the one
life lost is too many and and we grieve
today for the loss of more than 90,000
Americans to the coronavirus at a time
like this the first cabinet we meeting
that we
had since the advent of this epidemic
it's important to remember that when we
ask the American people to make all of
those sacrifices the estimates before
you were that if we did nothing
we could lose between 1 million and 2.2
million so Pence is being honest if we
did nothing doing nothing was not a
chance because by the time they decided
to do something many governors already
had which would drop that death toll so
Pence is actually knowingly or
unknowingly admitting the do-nothing
scenario is in a relevant scenario no
one would do nothing because governors
already had done stuff they we recognize
we recognize the progress that we have
made among the progress that we made mr.
president in flattening the curve and
slowing the spread was preserving as you
directed the capacity of our health care
system one of the great concerns that we
had early on was that our health care
system our hospital by the coronavirus
that did not occur mr. Voss truth is as
you've reflected many times because of
the ingenuity of the American people
because of our partnership with States
because of a great logistics team that
worked with the task force
no American who has needed a ventilator
was ever denied a ventilator unclear
that that's true it is an extraordinary
accomplishment the report that I
received today is that the national
stockpile now has more than 15,000
ventilators and that's in today's ago it
was 13,000 so like did they actually
just take delivery of 2,000 ventilators
which so where did they come from I
thought we were sending ventilators to
other countries how did our supply go
from 13 to 15 if we're sending hundreds
and hundreds of ventilators to other
countries just one of the questions
we'll never get an answer to frontlines
of this pandemic and on the subject of
testing mr. president when you tapped me
to lead this task force we had fully
done under the old system of public labs
we had fully done only 8400
virus tests at the end of February but
as you just reflected because of the
public-private partnership that you form
with commercial labs across the country
we are now form nearly 12 million
coronavirus tests and more than 400,000
in a single day
this past weekend and mr. president as
I'll share with the team as we're
increasing testing the good news to
Americans is nevertheless cases are
going down you've reflected on that and
your visit to the Capitol today and in
your opening remarks and in that I hope
despite the heartbreak and the hardship
that we've all endured I hope the
American people can sense that they've
made progress that as we continue to
scale testing all across the country our
our team with Admiral Joe are at the
helm and FEMA at the helm estimates that
we'll be able to conduct maybe 40 to 50
million tests a month by this September
and even as testings is expanding across
the country then that's the level we
need to even really look at reopening
they're saying it could be four more
months till we get to that level people
that's been challenged mr. president as
you rightly observed businesses large
and small who have had to shutter their
operations we've heard from restaurant
owners earlier this week thanks Gannon
we a great work of our secretary of the
Treasury and your leadership mr.
president a hundred and eighty eight
billion dollars in loans have been
approved to small businesses nearly five
hundred eighty three million have been
awarded through community health centers
all 50 states we have been there at the
point of the need for businesses large
and small we have been there for
vulnerable populations in a year
direction mr. president we'll continue
to lean forward in that fight the action
that you're taking today with signing
the executive order is going to make it
even more possible for us to to build
this economy back again for the American
people and it was in that spirit that
one month ago mr. president as I close
you directed the White House coronavirus
task force to release guidelines you
know Mike Pence says mr. president so
much to reengage Trump's attention
because otherwise Trump just you know
he's looking at papers and looking
around States as of today are partially
reopening their
economies and the American people are
responding and breathing that free air
again they're doing it responsibly
they're they're enjoying the opportunity
to be out in many states to enjoy
restaurants businesses opening back the
Big Three automakers went back to work
this last Monday in Ben Carson's
hometown of Detroit and America is on
its way back through a great great
season of hardship it's a testament to
the resilience of the American people
Wow so mr. president you charged the
White House coronavirus Task Force they
have one mission and that was save lives
to have one team and that was to forge
relationships all across the country
because of your leadership because of
the great work of this cabinet because
of governor's around the country but
mostly because of our incredible health
care workers and the cooperation of the
American people we've slowed the spread
we flattened the curve and we are
reopening I guess we won guys and mr.
president now I'm proud to report to you
that we're on our way
and I promise you this entire team is
going to continue to work with governors
around the country at your direction
until we bring the American economy all
the way back as you often say bigger and
better than ever before so thank you mr.
president
thank you very much Mike and again thank
you very much for doing a great job so
I'm going to sign this now and then Ben
and Steve will speak and then we'll go
around the room a little bit and we'll
say what we want I'd like to
congratulate Rick Whannell for doing
such a fantastic job as acting I don't
think you want to be permanent so I
think you're very happy to be acting but
what a job I think you'll go down as the
old-time great acting ever at any
position so thank you very much Rick
[Applause]
if you like to say something go ahead
please
short I would just say greetings from an
Intel community that is very interested
in providing policymakers everybody
around this table with raw intelligence
that is not politicized in any possible
way and I have to tell you mr. president
that I have heard from hundreds of
members of the current Intel community
that's one who are extremely pleased
with transparency of their work and
that's what they're shooting for that's
what they want to provide to
policymakers is information that is not
politicized by politicians in any way on
any side of the aisle but to be able to
protect their intelligence estimates we
all know that their estimates and
they're proud to give them when not
manipulated by others so this is
regulations are going to be cut and the
potential is that you're gonna find
regulations that nobody has ever thought
of before because you're gonna be doing
it yourselves and there's I understand
this so this is a this is an executive
order that regulations should be
examined and unnecessary regulations
should be cut
Trump vaguely mentioned it sometimes
takes a long time to build roads nothing
else has been specifically pointed out
Trump shouldn't need to sign this for
agencies to be able to evaluate how they
should be run which is essentially what
we're talking about this is complete gas
lighting it's completely meaningless
it's a photo-op Trump has its pens and
menudo that unfortunately this stuff
does seem to bamboozle some some of his
followers into thinking he's doing stuff
but it's very very important Alain you
can do things that nobody would believe
in your department Department of
Transportation so good luck and I'm
signing this it gives you tremendous
power to cut regulations yeah this is
this is total [ __ ]
I think most of you understand that
[Music]
and then out sharpies by the way that
signature is getting more about it okay
Ben would you like to say something yeah
yes sir Thank You mr. president and a
big thank you to all the cabinet members
almost everybody has been deeply
involved in the refocusing of the
opportunity and revitalization council
sleepy ben Carson Jared and Kristen and
Brooke also big big help Oh Brooke
justice was done during the greatest
generation many sectors of our society
are being reconfigured to meet the
singler goal of winning our war against
this invisible enemy companies that made
bedding linen are now making mask and
place David the see vehicles are now
producing ventilators I worked at some
of those plants growing up in each way
and now the White House opportunity and
revitalization Council which was formed
by you to help long-forgotten
communities achieve Economic Opportunity
will refocus and expand to help
America's hardest hit communities and
achieve economic recovery overcome
health disparities and thrive through
educational advancement education being
the ticket it doesn't matter where you
came from you get a good education you
can write your own ticket since your
historic tax cuts and Jobs Act millions
of dollars from the private sector have
been invested in these designated
opportunity zones which are home to
nearly 35 million people through this
initiative we foster partnerships
between people who sell them sit down
together we're talking about business
leaders community leaders faith-based
leaders housing advocates investors can
you get on my state and local and
federal officials the revitalization
Council which I have the privilege to
change
alongside our executive director Scott
Turner who's hinted here in this rooms
thanks Luke
other areas over there okay has played a
big role in the success identify more
than 270 different federal actions to
support and increase investment in
opportunity zones through things like
grant preference points loan
qualifications reduce fees eligibility
criteria modifications and a number of
other incentives in a true direction
we're now taking our considerable
capacity to discover opportunity and
drive recovery and disadvantaged and
minority communities that are
disproportionately affected by kovat 19
based on our work and analysis
revitalization council is identifying
diverse policy approaches in areas
including housing education technology
broadband workforce entrepreneurship
health and long term Community
Development and under your leadership
this administration has shined a light
on the Forgotten men and women right
whose job perspect prospects and health
disparities are often hidden in the
shadows mr. president you've been a
champion for all Americans especially
our low-income and minority communities
why and we're committed to continuing
continuing your work not only to restore
but to advance the historic gains and
prosperity many enjoyed before this
global epidemic your council will not
only continue its focus to bring more
jobs and better jobs but it will also
expand to better fortify public health
services that will improve medical and
social health outcomes and uplift our
most distressed communities the American
people will come out the other side of
this crisis stronger and more determined
than ever thanks to the authority you
have vested in the vet revitalization
council we will leverage these powers to
heal America's hardest hit communities
and return to prosperity as safely and
swiftly as possible and thank you for
not giving in to the naysayers and to
the people who use fear to control and
instead giving people hope
right not with just your words but with
your actions thank you
well thank you very much but you know I
had to run against him and he was very
tough yeah and he was even tougher when
he'd run onto a stage holding a Bible up
in the year that was tough I said that's
tough to beat but I said if I'm ever so
lucky I don't want him in the
administration so that's what happened
and you've done a great job thank you
very much Steve were we and what are we
doing Thank You mr. president so I'm
pleased to report your administration
has been hard at work implementing the
cares Act we've really made incredible
progress over the last month working on
putting over three trillion dollars into
the economy unprecedented amount of
support for American business and
American workers and I just want to
highlight a few of the things working
with SBA we were able to develop the
Paycheck protection program from scratch
that's now impacted over 4.3 million
companies impacting over 50 million
workers minuchin is really a disgrace to
the last name so minuchin the the the
root of that last name it's a it's a
it's a Jewish last name there's an
Argentinean actor one Manoogian which
it's essentially the same last name it's
like it's like a Spanish if I'd version
of that last name fantastic actor and
he's in some some great programs and
every time I see minuchin like man what
what a disgrace to the name this guy is
deserve I have approved nine special
facilities totaling about two and a half
trillion dollars that's about half of
our capacity and in particular I just
like to highlight the Main Street
lending program which is your small and
mid market companies will be up and
running by the end of this month and
then I would just comment on the
economic impact payments mr. president
have really had a big impact we've
delivered over 239 billion dollars to
141
million Americans and I want to
highlight we couldn't be more pleased
114 million of those we did direct
deposit into people's accounts we did 27
million checks and mr. president we now
have developed demo cards so in an
effort to expedite money to people even
quicker in a very safe way I'm pleased
to show you what a debit card looks like
with your name on Trump now there's no
money for you on it this is a blank
debit card but I want you to see now if
you get a debit card can you deposit the
money into your bank account because it
seems some people may want to deposit
the money into their bank account I
don't know how you pay rent or a
mortgage with a credit card a debit card
so I saw the letter again a great career
had a great educational career
tremendous student and went on to very
very tremendous business success and
what a good boy all of that experience
was necessary for what you're doing
right but there's nobody better with
money and controlling money and handling
money so I want to thank you very much
thank you Alex please well thank you mr.
president you know your top priority has
always been the health safety and
well-being of the American people as
we've been going through this pandemic
just as a reminder remember at one point
Alex azar hired a former Labradoodle
breeder to run the day-to-day
coronavirus operations the roaring Trump
economy and we have the tools to do that
the right mindset for reopening is not
about balancing health versus the
economy it's actually about balancing
health versus health by one estimate the
virus induced recession will see an
extra 65,000 deaths from suicide drug
overdose alcohol abuse in the coming
years possibly even more states are
seeing a decline in the reporting of
child maltreatment because kids aren't
at school they're not seeing doctors and
teachers who would otherwise report
maltreatment in the home environment and
so it goes on addressed mammograms are
down 87% colonoscopies are down
90% approximately 1.7 million new cancer
cases are diagnosed per year in our
country and if we're seeing an 80
percent drop in cancer cases identified
we could already have 300,000 or more
undiagnosed cancer cases as a result of
this crisis a CDC report found a 60%
reduction in vaccine administration
including four this is actually for real
like this is actually really a concern
and we do have to figure that out how to
get that going again in Massachusetts is
starting to get it going this is not an
area where they are wrong we have the
surveillance tools we have the testing
tools we have the containment
methodologies and resources we are
developing therapeutics and we're
developing vaccines so we have the
strategy and the recipe to support the
safe reopening of our economy and for
the sake of Americans health and
well-being we've got to support this and
move ahead with safe reopening you know
I mentioned some of the physical health
risks of the of keeping our country
closed down but we have here today with
us our assistant secretary for substance
abuse for mental health and substance
abuse
dr. Ellie McCants Katz who's a support
that person talks in Japan suicides are
down 20% because work and commuting are
such sources of stress in Japan suicides
they're down 20% that's not what Trump
predicted first if that's okay mr.
brother we'd love that
please doctor
mr. president vice president pence
members of the cabinet and colleagues
okay as I've listened to states and
communities struggle with mental mental
illness issues for years and as a result
of the virus I wanted to ensure that
governor's yesterday heard these
concerns from a medical perspective as
my physician colleagues on the task
force have been careful to rightly note
their perspective and advice center is
on one aspect of the pandemic virus
containment however even medically it is
not the sole perspective I felt that it
was important to offer the governor's a
different I'll be an equally important
medical perspective as such I made the
following remarks it is my privilege to
serve as the assistant secretary for
mental health and substance use but
today I really speak to you more as a
psychiatrist who also happens to hold a
PhD in infectious disease epidemiology
never did I imagine the nation would be
experiencing the coinciding of mental
health issues and infectious disease
that my training addressed the research
literature is clear on the effects of
quarantine and stay-at-home practices on
mental health we know that the longer
the duration of these orders the greater
the intensity of the mental health
problems experienced we also know that
these symptoms persist for years to come
even once quarantine is lifted the data
tell us that when the lives of adults
children and families are drastically
changed for extended lengths of time for
many anxiety depression and stress
disorders well the funny now they make a
huge deal out of mental health and
rightly so but then normally they want
exclusions for mental health services
from health insurance coverage and they
don't take it seriously now it's a put
it's a useful political tool to argue
for reopening pre-pandemic we lose
120,000 lives a year to drug overdose
and suicide how many more lives are we
willing to sacrifice in the name of
containing the virus when we look at
strategies to reopen as a medical doctor
I ask that you take into account whole
health not just one narrow aspect of
physical health we continually as
our selves what the health costs and
risks maybe of reopening but I ask what
might they be of not reopening or
reopening in such a restrictive way that
American lives are not restored of
course containing the effects of
coronavirus are critically important but
so too is preventing suicide so too is
keeping a person from being terrified to
ever leave their home so too is
protecting the mental health of our
nation's young people I ask you to
remember that not every home is a safe
home not every individual can withstand
the trauma of not seeing or interacting
physically with loved ones not every
parent can survive the mental anguish of
not being able to feed their children
because of lost employee this is so
short-sighted like the reason to
unsafely open can't be that homes are so
bad that we need to get people out like
if there's hunger at home the solution
isn't unsafely open schools it's let's
fix hunger at home which we could have
fixed 20 years ago but there's no
political will to do this is all
backwards
for millions of additional Americans and
if we are doing those things
why have we decided collectively that
this is okay we've worked so hard in
states and communities across this
country to combat epidemics like the
opioids crisis why are we willing to
forget those efforts now are deemed them
less important as a psychiatrist I would
argue that a life lost to suicide is
just as important as a life lost to
coronavirus a family who loses someone
to drug overdose experiences the same
grief as a family who loses a loved one
to coronavirus this guy does not forget
that all American lives are precious our
citizens count on us to remember their
health and safety in all aspects of life
the preservation of Americans of health
and the health of our citizens cannot be
measured by only one metric virus
containment cannot be our only goal no
matter the cost to Americans if we
ignore the reality of the enormous
mental health strain we've put on our
citizens on the backdrop of an already
overburdened mental health care system
I'm saddened but certain that the next
major public health crisis of our time
be that of mental and substance use
disorders and it is not far behind I
urge you to factor this reality into
your planning and I thank you for the
work you've done thus far on behalf of
the millions of Americans with mental
and substance use disorders holy [ __ ]
thank you very much doctor appreciate it
very sobering that's tough that's very
tough but we're getting there we're
getting back and that's very important
thank you great job I'd like to ask Chad
Wolfe from Homeland Security just to say
maybe discuss the record-low numbers we
have of people crossing the border
they're taking at your direction in the
vice president's direction the task
force we've taken a number of measures
that protecting public health proactive
and imprudent measures at the border
those include non-essential travel
restrictions that we have with both
Canada and Mexico
there's also include continued
construction of the border wall system
now as importantly new measures that
we've instituted along that southwest
border regarding illegal border entries
and those are the numbers that you're
referring to last month in April we had
a little under 17,000 folks that cross
the border illegally compared that to a
year ago April of nineteen was over a
hundred and twenty thousand individuals
so we're all brought out is that because
of anything we're doing or is that the
circumstances I generally don't
genuinely don't know 80 cent back 80
percent of those 17,000 were removed
within a hundred and twenty minutes two
hours the rest to just a little bit
longer but are continuing to be removed
as well so and that's a first
that's a first in the last 40 years
that's absolutely right again at the at
your leadership the task force
leadership would continue to make
progress on that border
thank you very much Chad thanks Chad
also mark Meadows who's our chief of
staff is that giga chat or not i can't
tell well he's very popular in north
carolina he had a seat that was very
easy for him to keep and I talked to him
long and hard for a while long and hard
that's a friend of mine but he's he's
going to go down as the ultimate
hopefully chief of staff so mark it's
really nice to have you would you like
to say a few words Thank You mr.
president
your work in the work of this cabinet on
behalf of the American people is very
evident it's critical that we make sure
that Americans are healthy safe secure
and prosperous and because of the work
of everyone around this table and more
importantly your leadership we're
setting the example of how not only to
tackle one of the most difficult silent
killers that we've ever faced in our
history but also how to come out of that
more United and because of your
executive order today we are not only
ready to reopen our [ __ ] country well
we're open for business once again so I
thank you I was almost an honor to serve
you in the people of this great country
thank you very much for doing really
really well appreciate it looking on our
guns with UK United Kingdom and I hear
they want to very much do it and we'd
like to do it how we all want to do it
we're doing well I'm never too hard to
do a deal as you know so yeah we'll see
how that works out I would like to
report though that on July 1st we'll
have USMC a fully in effect which is
just in time for the reopening we'll
have the new rules that will help
American workers farmers ranchers and
we're now beginning to see some
substantial new sales I defer to Sonny
of course on agriculture something there
is a variety of others because of this
and the other deals that you've done but
in terms of the UK deal where we're just
beginning that and we'll see how that
turns as you said to me a thousand times
we'll see how that turns out what I'm
asked we'll see how that turns out
through experience you never know you
never know do you
well we usually do and actually we've
signed a great deal with Japan 40
billion dollars we've created a new deal
with South Korea which was many many
billions of dollars it was a defective
deal now it's a very good deal effective
but us Anjali the largest trade deal
ever made anywhere in the world people
don't realize the amount of business
that we do with Canada
and with Mexico is monumental it's the
biggest trade deal in the world bigger
than the deal we made with China people
don't be a super chat China deal is
kicking in they're buying a lot but I
feel differently now about that deal
that I did three months ago and we'll
see what all happens but it's been a
very disappointing situation very
disappointing thing happened with China
because the plague flowed in now that
wasn't supposed to happen and it could
have been stopped so I want to thank you
very much you're doing really a
fantastic deal you have a lot of Records
and one of the people I wanted to get
when I was elected was Bob light Iser
because he had the record and really had
the reputation as being the best trade
negotiator anywhere in the world
everybody respected he was the authority
so I got him and you've lived up to your
every action now let's see if you can
exceed it you have plenty of work to do
how was it going with you say four years
four more years to do I know the Boris
the first thing Boris did when he got
when fortunately he was better cuz he's
a great guy Boris Johnson Prime Minister
he called me and he wanted to talk about
the trade deal how's it going that was
his first words to me how was the trade
deal going I said how are you feeling so
it was really some be more of our my job
was his first words after waking up from
you know of a sedation right that would
be more interesting than just the first
thing he says to Trump out of traveling
working hard anything to say Mike so I
just add that in the course of this
we've brought ninety-three thousand
Americans back home who were stuck
because travel had ceased stage forms
done fantastic work getting these
Americans back to their families are
still a few more out there I work to do
and we're working to make sure that the
global economy gets back on its feet too
so along with Department of Homeland
Security Department of Transportation
trying to make sure that all the process
is a place so people can travel again in
the way that they did before this virus
hit this entire world good Mike
interesting chair I'd like to maybe ask
Scott Turner to finish he's somebody
who's young and strong and powerful and
he's done an incredible job with
Opportunity Zones and other things and
maybe you could finish it off
and we could take a couple of questions
from enemies like but Scott make the
media so crazed that they say boy are
they doing a great job someone turned on
his mic please oh boy
Carson oh my god you know I was sitting
here listening tada remarks and I was
reminded of my time from peewee football
all the way to the NFL oh yeah something
about all of them what is the greatest
time that we had was the huddle the last
time I was with you I was last summer we
had traveled to 21 cities in 12 weeks
and y'all encouraged me greatly and so
we finished by traveling to over 60
cities with the opportunity zone and the
council and much fruit came about in
America because of the White House
opportunity a revitalization council
just cut it guys I haven't muted it just
so everybody knows Elaine Chao making a
note get working microphone for myself
never sit in front of this guy again
they must have muted it I mean I've not
touched anything guys just so you know I
also saw a vision mm-hmm incredibly
inspirational message the part that
really sticks with me is when he likened
this to peewee football that's really
the way I act to the huddle yeah in the
holler it was a time to refocus it was a
time to reset and courage I know you got
beat on that you what me get beat on the
next one we have you we have your back
we were a team the enemy was on the
other side what an event guys
Oh 18 that is Kovac and I want to remind
everybody in the room and everybody
listening in America what are one take
right this is the huddle
today we're encouraging each other we
have each other's back we know to
anticipate what's happening on the next
play we have a great game plan we got
great leadership lean showers all around
imagine that this guy was mean not three
weeks but imagine this guy spent the
last day really didn't sleep
anticipating this moment it might look
out because we're going to be victorious
right
I guess the enemy and heaven and the
generation of vision yep so long but I
come behind those I want y'all to be
encouraging president all of you for
your leadership
yeah and I'm encouraged to be here so
thank you I'm not encouraged by the
sound guy well I think we saw in the
mirror so you know we have a couple of
seats available congressional seats
where I'm not overly impressed with the
candidate and I think would you like to
move to a little different section of
the United States because I could
guarantee this guy would be in Congress
in about two minutes and you know I know
somebody that knew Scott from the NFL I
said what kind of a player was he he
said he was fast but more than anything
else he was tough he was just mean and
tough right and that's what we want he's
tough but he's got a great heart he's
got a great heart and I've known him now
a long time Scott and we know he's got a
long time but he had to ask other people
how he played football weird weird story
dude okay any questions please yes Steve
let's go right to hydroxy they're not
miked up
no it just seems to mean less to me
because you know we did this great deal
with China they have to buy billions and
billions of dollars of product farm
product and other product and it was
very exciting one of the biggest deals
ever made actually not as big as the
u.s. MCA which surprises people but it
could have been bigger over a period of
time huge deal with China the potential
of the people getting in a sense and it
was very exciting but once the virus
came in once the plague is I call it
came in I said how did they let that
happen how did they let that happen
and how come it didn't go into other
sections of China why did they block it
from leaving Wuhan right but they didn't
block it from going to the rest of the
world including the United States why is
that Beijing doesn't have it other
places don't have it they walk down so
why is it that it was blocked very
effectively from leaving that area and
going into China yeah but we know it
went out to the rest of the world
including the United States and why
didn't they let us go in and help them
fix it so I'm very disappointed in China
yeah
they've got to mic up the press they've
got to make them up I don't talk about
retaliation go ahead I think I think
we've announced a plan we're opening up
our country just a rude person you are
yeah we're opening up our country nasty
person opening it up very fast the plan
is that each state is opening and it's
opening up very effectively and when you
see the numbers I think does he ever say
that the male journalists are nasty I'm
actually not sure now Thank You mr.
president
Canada has confirmed that the board is
going to remain closed until June 21st
10 days before right UMS yes and see
aren't you worried for the economy on
the board of states yeah we do and we
speak to Canada all the time obviously
the relationship is very good with the
Prime Minister and myself and with the
two countries you know Canada's our
neighbor we have a great relationship we
love Canada
so we're gonna be talking and at the
right time we'll open that up very
quickly that'll go very easily yep yes
it could happen before June 21st yeah it
could sure it could they do it well
we're doing well we're both doing well
thank you uh mr. president you've said
repeatedly that the United States is now
the king of ventilators and that we have
so many that we're sending them overseas
selling them then in some cases actually
gifting them to other countries my
question is are you looking to use these
diplomatic aliy to strengthen ties with
other nations and their difficulties
influencing some parts of the world no
I'm not looking to do diplomatically I'm
looking to save lives if we can save
lives of another country that's a great
thing so I'm only looking to save lives
probably that's good diplomatically but
I'm not looking at that you have
countries that have no chance to have
real ventilators they would they don't
have a capacity to build them and we're
sending hundreds and even thousands and
we have thousands now and they're being
produced at a very rapid again if we're
sending thousands how did our stockpile
go up by 2,000 in the last four days
from 13 to 15,000 I just don't get it
guys
I just want to know how he had none
essentially we had very few and they
were obsolete they were broken we're
building not only a lot of them but we
have a very high-quality ventilator one
of the highest so countries know that
and they're calling us and they're
asking for help they need help so I I
only think in terms of saving lives the
country we've gotten some very unusual
calls from people that normally wouldn't
be calling us to easily calling asking
for help you know you can get swabs and
you can get gowns and you can get a lot
of things but getting ventilators is
very tough very very tough because it's
a very complex machine for expensive
machine so we've done a very good job
and probably it does help diplomatically
but we do it for helping people's lives
save lives
yes please yeah do you so Ford Motor
Company has previously required visitors
to wear masks when they visit their
facilities do you plan to wear one when
you go there on Thursday I don't know
it's I haven't even thought of it it
depends I mean I mean some areas I would
in certain areas I don't but I will
certainly look at it it depends on what
situation am i standing right next to
everybody or am i spread out that means
now and also you look you know is
something a hospital is it a ward is it
what is it exactly I like what I'm
saying to a hospital and they'll see
where it's appropriate I would do it
certainly helping minority communities
what specifically are you looking at a
lot of things so one of the things I was
most proud of was the minority community
and all of the work we've done for the
minority communities black unemployment
Hispanic unemployment what Asia
non-human was the best ever in the
history of our country we've never had
anything like it we've never had so many
african-american jobs ever ever in the
history of our country by far we have a
lot of black jobs right now in our
country back and a big focus is exactly
that with the minorities specifically
look Larry yeah the Asians
they've done incredibly well incredible
antics incredibly well african-americans
record-setting every month you know that
every month so he was asked what he's
done he's listing ethnicities and races
that's what he's doing when I get it
back to that level
we had to artificially close our country
one day we had it we did the right thing
we were to lost millions of lives if we
didn't think of it if we lost a hundred
thousand lives the minimum we would have
lost is a million two million three
million five maybe but take it to a
million so that would mean ten times
more that we lost already now I've seen
hospitals like Elmhurst Queens where I
grew up near that I know that hospital
where they had one day eleven body bags
in a hallway and they had some outside
and that they had refrigerated trucks
coming to take bodies away remember guys
Moulton was what specifically have you
done for minorities disproportionately
impacted by the virus he's talking about
body bags lowest number possible it
probably would have been times 20 or
maybe 25 so we did the right thing but
now we have to get back to work
and we want to open up and the people
want to open up but we've learned a lot
about the disease question was what have
you done for minorities he listed races
and then talked about body bags we've
learned about the washing of hands I
used to wash my hands all up but I tell
you right now I wash you're more yeah we
learned a lot and we also learned how to
put out the embers or the fires whatever
may come we learned without having to
close down the whole country and we have
big sections of our country that don't
have much of a problem we have
subsections that don't have any problem
question was what have you done
specifically for minorities who are
doing really well and most excitingly
we're working on vaccines therapeutics
and cures that are really moving along
at a level that nobody would have
thought possible and the military I
could say mark a spur okay you know mark
aspirin question was what are we done
for minorities he's talking about the
military because his military is going
to be distributing whether it doesn't it
seem like the question was
a month ago at this point cures or
whether it's a vaccine and and by the
way I have to say all three are doing
unbelievably well but mark and the
military are gonna be getting him out so
he has hundreds of thousands of people
that he is immediately that and what did
you do for minorities specifically to
deploy they're ready to get the job done
they'll be doing it in a record business
and everything we've done with the
military has been terrific we've had
Admirals we've had generals I remember
when Kryon Chuck Schumer said we should
get the military involved I said they
are
he said we should use one of our
generals I said we do our generals have
done a great job Jared right and our
Admirals have done a great we had
everybody involved and they are once ate
a taco salad that could maybe be thrown
into this answer they fight they're
great fighters and they fight but yeah
the minority communities are really
going to be well served I think we are
going to get that right back around and
this includes everybody this includes
our whole country but right back to
where it was which was record-setting
numbers yep it's right now that you are
considering for those communities right
now we're opening up areas and a lot of
people are getting jobs I heard some
numbers yesterday that we're really
incredible the amount loser synergize of
the country that opened up so quickly
over the last few days think you're
going to see some very big numbers and I
think next year is gonna be an
incredible year economically you can
never make up for all of the loss of
life you can never do that can't do it
from an economic standpoint however next
year is going to be I think it's going
to be potentially a great year for us
yeah hopefully under a different
presidents
no that's not what I was no no there was
a false study done where they gave it to
very sick people extremely sick people
here we go people that were ready to die
he was given by obviously not friends of
the administration it was done by your
NJ the study came out the people were
ready to die
everybody was old had bad problems with
hearts diabetes and everything else you
can imagine
so they gave it so immediately when it
came out they gave a lot of false
information just so you understand great
studies came out of Italy on hydroxy you
know what I'm talking about right right
great studies came out and the
combination of the three but we had some
great studies come out Italy France
Spain ourselves many many doctors
doctors many doctors came out and they
said oxes it's great now you have to go
to a doctor I have a doctor in the white
house I said what do you think and it's
just a line of defense I'm just talking
about as a line of defense I'm dealing
with a lot of people look at all the
people in there I would love them to be
asked what's the frequency of the dosage
and it's a very inexpensive drug it's
it's almost pennies Doc's very
inexpensive and it's been out for close
to 70 years for a couple of different
things right lupus and malaria element
even arthritis they say but I think it's
worth it as a line of defense and I'll
stay order for a little while longer I'm
just very curious myself
but it seems to be very safe but that
study was a phony study put out by the
VA fake that you may want to talk about
that I mean we could talk about that if
we've done but he wants to and maybe I
guess Kyle is Alex to talk about then if
you would introduce our great talented
head of the VA and let him say a couple
of words but that was a phony stuff with
the VA and it's very dangerous to do it
the fact is people should want to help
people not to make political points it's
really sad when they do that go ahead
so hydroxychloroquine has been approved
by the FDA for decades here in the
United States now a corona buyer for the
Prevention of malaria treatment of lupus
treatment of rheumatoid arthritis and
the system we have here in the United
States that is once a drug has been
approved and on the market a doctor and
consultation with the patient may use it
for what we call off-label purposes
which are not yet proven child's right
to try president he for the first time
about the historic right to try
legislation for experimental therapies
but story-wise to our existing regime
which is approved products may be used
in the judgment of a physician in
consultation with their patient the
president said in Alaska secretary will
key to talk a bit about the VA study
there there's been there's been some
studies around the use of hydroxyl
Kuwait is there a guy gonna trash the VA
zone study we are still working on some
controlled studies earlier in the
disease progression to see if we can
measure the effectiveness of it in
preventing the replication of the virus
and spread in mild to moderate cases
rather than the more serious and that
data is still pending but and it's good
well it's gotten very good reviews very
good from many many doctor rate mark
many many doctors secretary listen thank
you mr. president I and I want to clear
up something that the media has not
reported accurately that was not a VA
can you hear him because I think it's
important you asked the question no that
was because I don't even think you're
listening yeah go ahead why don't you
listen with him no that was not a study
researchers took VA numbers and they did
not clinically review them they were not
peer reviewed they did not even look at
what the president just mentioned the
various comorbidities that it was an RCT
who were referenced in that study had I
also want to echo what the Secretary of
HHS said the instructions I received
from the president were very clear and
that was to preserve and protect life
that's the best RCT we currently have
around this table we've been taking this
drug for years as the president
mentioned the Department of Defense and
VA have been using it for 65 years on
every any given day VA uses 42
and doses of this drug and what we did
when this virus first hit us was to use
every means necessary to help preserve
life we believed that the Congress was
right and the President signed
legislation to protect life the right to
try and we did this in consultation not
only with the families of those veterans
but we did this in consultation with our
doctors under FDA guidelines so I want
to knock down the phony story that this
is somehow this guy's not going back on
what the president told us to do which
was to use every means possible to
protect and preserve the lives of the
lives of our veterans and I think as the
president mentioned we've seen in many
cases across this country in fact I was
on the news the day that the governor of
New York was asking you for tens of
thousands of doses that's right we are
doing we can some people and this is one
of the means that we used Thank You
hydroxychloroquine is used by thousands
and thousands of frontline workers so
that hopefully they don't catch this
horrible disease or whatever you want to
call it it is a terrible virus it's a
terrible thing and a lot of people are
taking it a lot of doctors are taking it
a lot of people swear by it it's gotten
a bad reputation only because I'm
promoting it so I'm obviously a very bad
promoter it's if anybody else we're
promoting it they'd say this is the
greatest thing ever but because of me so
a lot of doctors swear by it I think we
can say that mr. secretary a lot of
doctors think it's great but the one
thing that is true one way or the other
way they like it or not it's been around
for 70 years
unbelievably as a welcome for malaria
and Filippis that's probably effective
for arthritis and what has been
determined is it doesn't harm you that's
not a very powerful drug I guess but it
doesn't harm you
and so I thought
as a frontline defense possibly it would
be good and I've had no impact from it
I've had no I feel the same I haven't
changed I don't think too much and at
some point you know I won't take it
might be soon might be a little bit it
doesn't it doesn't seem to have any
impact on me but it seems to be a extra
line of defense and it's gotten
tremendous reviews from some people this
is amazing many many doctors all over
the world and you should look at some of
the studies they've been amazing some of
the studies but that's up to people one
of them I think strongly recommend to
people with their doctor's advice and
acknowledgement okay I don't know I
don't know that's a personal thing as to
whether or not they want to answer that
question but I think many of them would
take it if they felt it was necessary I
also had a case where we had somebody
fairly close to me very nice young
gentleman he tested positive and he
tested positive plus I deal with Micah
like a lot and my kids somebody very
close to him who I also see who tested
positive so I think I thought you know
from my standpoint not a bad time to
take it he should also just take does if
he knows we had the combination
obviously why not I mean what's to
people in what he absolutely big
building with a lot of people work and
some plasma but so I thought it would be
appropriate but it has had no impact in
terms of me okay and I just want to ask
you a question on Brazil whose result
it's not yes in third position place now
catching up to Russia and second place
for number of cases are you finally
considering a travel ban from from
Brazil and Lebanon we are considering it
we hope that we're not gonna have a
problem
the governor Florida's doing very very
well testing it's in particular Florida
cos would you already come into Florida
Brazil has gone more or less heard you
know what that is heard and they're
having problems by the way you know when
you say that we lead in cases that's
because we have more testing than
anybody else that's not so we test much
more than anybody else
39 again we're close to 14 million it
was said
twelve twelve and a half it's actually I
think close to fourteen million now
no it's eleven so we have fourteen
million tests and Germany if they do two
million that's a lot and others are
doing 1 million so if you're testing 14
million people you're gonna find many
more cases many of these people aren't
very sick but they still go down as
accounts so actually the number of cases
and we're also a much bigger country
than most
that's what per capita so when we have a
lot of cases I don't look at that as a
bad thing I look at that as in a certain
respect as being it's a great a good
thing because it means our testing is
much heythis for everybody it's great if
we were testing a million people instead
of 14 million people we would have far
fewer ASI you guys all understand we're
38th per capita I know you I know I
don't have to explain it to you guys
really it's a badge of honor it's a
great tribute to the testing and all of
the work that a lot of professionals
have done right that they're gonna bring
their I mean as to your the first part
of your question yeah I sure I worry
about everything I don't want people
coming in here and affecting our people
in fact I don't want people over there
sick either we're helping Brazil with
ventilators we're sending them
ventilators okay they they need
ventilators I'm sending them ventilators
we have so many thousands of them we're
sending them right we're sending a lot
of people know Brazil is having some
trouble no question about it
Sweden by the way you know I've heard a
lot about Sweden and the way they do
well they have you have Norway Denmark
Finland Sweden that little group of
beautiful countries yep well Sweden took
a little different attitude but Sweden
has far more deaths than the other three
you know they do you know that yeah
death many times the deaths but they did
it a different way and you know I
understand that too and and as Mike said
very well before there is death on both
sides right it's death on both sides
there's death and staying in a shutdown
also yeah by the way I think and
everybody grabbing memberships I do see
them and I really appreciate it okay
[Music]
I'd love it to open up as soon as it can
but we have to make sure that we're
doing well and they're doing well and in
many cases we are but you know we have a
very big country we have some areas that
have done incredibly well we have other
areas where the results are it's tougher
New York and New Jersey are tougher
people don't realize New Jersey is the
most dense state a lot of people don't
realize it governor is a terrific person
he's very liberal but that's okay he's a
very liberal guy but we like him kind of
like the mayor and he's working very
hard but New Jersey is a very dense area
very very dense and I speak to Andrew a
lot Andrew Cuomo a lot we're working
very well together and you know those
are the two spots that have really been
very heavily hit a big portion a big
percentage I don't know what it is it's
a very big percentage almost half of our
deaths would be to those two now at the
same time the numbers even in those two
places are coming down they're coming
down very rapidly and I put out
yesterday's statement numbers are coming
down with the exception of very little
few exceptions the numbers are coming
down all over the United States very
rapidly very rapidly it's a beautiful
thing to watch but it's left behind
serious death and it shouldn't have
happened thank you very much everybody
thank you so does Trump to sit now or
what happens now Wow Wow that petulant
child thing that he does unbelievable
thanks to everybody who joined me I do
want it so many great people grab
memberships Angela Corbett and Cameron
Callahan Samuel Carter signed up at join
pakman.com Tom sell [ __ ] go I hope I
pronounced that correctly join
pakman.com is the place 2020 now is the
coupon code David Martinez Kayla fish
Dan praising Danielle Jones karidian I
think I already think really really
appreciate it make sure to hit that like
subscribe button if you're on Twitch
make sure to fall
my channel and we'll be back with you I
would predict predict to take a phrase
out of Trump's vocabulary I believe that
over the next period of time I will be
back with you very very strongly
you